What's astonishing to me is how anytime something does come out on Trump,
it just seems to slide right off.
Yeah.
Well that is true.
That is true,
isn't it?
Because I think what's happening is they're just throwing everything out there
every day.
Right?
Yeah.
Much like,
you know,
our willingness to give up privacy because we keep hearing about another hack or
another lake or we know that Amazon's doing this or that.
I think it's that constant drum beat and that mudslinging and I think the dems
haven't done themselves any favors.
So the resistance movement or what do we want to call it?
Um,
because I think people are just immune to it and it's hardened the Trump's base
to think,
you know,
he's under attack every minute,
so I gotta support them harder.
Um,
yeah.
But,
uh,
you know,
who do you think's going to end up in,
in the race?
I mean,
who's got the best chance?
A good question.
I mean,
on the left hand side,
I,
the,
my real fear is that Hillary was going to run again.
So I almost did one of those TV spit takes.
It's possible.
[inaudible] when lady is crazy,
you know,
one of the things that she said and one of the more recent interviews,
she said,
I'd like to be president.
Just what do you,
what do you want to put it on your resume?
What the fuck does that mean?
I think I could do a great job and turning this country around.
I have the leadership ability to really affect a change.
No,
no,
no.
I'd like to be president.
I got some time I could do that.
I'm scared of them.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
and you're right.
She May,
but I,
I,
I do think it's going to be so much pressure on her from the party to just say,
no,
you can't.
I think she's going to look at that and go,
I,
there's no chance I can rally the apparatus around me like I did the last time.
And because of that,
um,
because even she can't run without the machine.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
they've got to figure that out.
So I just wonder if she has so many people that owe her favors and she's so
deeply entrenched in the world that she could somehow,
or another muster up enough support to give it one more shot.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's possible.
I mean,
yeah,
but then you're talking about her all the way to two.
What to,
to,
uh,
Kamala Harris,
Cory booker,
Tulsi Gabbert Tulsi Gabbard Telsey Guillard Castro was a veteran.
Young makes a lot of sense.
Very smart,
articulate.
I think she has a real legitimate chance of getting people excited about a real
future.
Yeah.
I would not,
uh,
you know,
I think it's time was certainly close.
We're getting to that point where we'll,
uh,
you know,
we end up with a female president and hey,
good for us.
Right.
I got no problems.
You know,
there's,
I think it would actually,
you know,
I think it would turn the ship in a nice direction,
right.
As long as the policies are good,
I don't care who it is.
As long as we're not veering off into,
uh,
you know,
sort of socialist policy,
land and thinking,
somehow we're going to all going to end up with a universal basic income.